A good example of this, relating to the brain, is a trait called Huntington's
Disease. Huntington's disease, is a neurodegenerative disorder that affects
muscle coordination and results in cognitive decline and psychiatric problems.
Caused by a marked degeneration of brain tissue, that's visible in this
picture. Comparing a Huntington's Disease brain on the left to normal brain
tissue here on the right. Typically, Huntington's Disease becomes noticeable in
mid adult life. So if the allele for Huntington's Disease is dominant. Then
which of the following allele combinations would result in someone who actually
displays Huntington's Disease? Remember, humans have two copies of every gene.
We'll represent the allele for Huntington's Disease with the letters HD and the
allele for normal brain function with the abbreviation NORM. Would it be
somebody who has two HD alleles. An individual with one HD and one NORM allele
or an individual with two NORM alleles. Go ahead and select any and all answers
that you think apply. [BLANK_AUDIO]